c'est une vieille tradition américaine
des années 50 qui débarque dans les
prairies du loir et cher qu'on fait dans
la rangée justice ici ou là sur un écran
de 111 mètres carrés posé au milieu d'un
aérodrome 250 voitures viennent assister
à la première séance du plus grand drive
ile de france
un projet né il ya trois semaines
seulement pour permettre au cinéma
confiné de se réinventer le septième art
a beaucoup souffert de la crise les
salles obscures ont été fermés depuis
trop longtemps désormais les gens ont
besoin de sortir et ont besoin de peut
être devenir voir aussi de bons films
ici mais ce drive in et surtout un
hommage aux films des années 50 à nos
jours dans un esprit pop corn et barbe à
papa
c'était un petit peu cette idée est de
retrouver cette ambiance des années 50
dans lequel va les gens allaient au
cinéma en famille en mangeant du pop
corn avec les fichiers du patin à
roulettes entre les voitures
c'était un petit peu cette idée là et
donc on avait un peu la même idée avec
nicolas c'est pour ça qu'on allait foot
rock c'est pour ça qu'on est en plein
air et c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi des
films qui sont vraiment des films les
films cultes
à l'affiché ce soir
bohemian rhapsody le biopic devenu culte
sur la vie de freddie mercury
les répliques s'écoute désormais sur le
poste de radio via une bande fm
et quand les plus jeunes explora peine
les plaisirs du drive-in d'autres les
redécouvre vous aviez déjà regardé un
film en drive-in depuis votre voiture
pas de cette voiture est pas en
allemagne
nous sommes des hommes ça vous rappelle
des souvenirs
c'est dans un entrain dans une ambiance
un peu spéciale puisque on est vraiment
dans son propre dans sa voiture donc
c'est différent mais fait original et ça
fait du bien de sortir un peu de chez
soi y découvrir un film
quarante sept films seront projetés ici
chaque soir jusqu'au 1er août
dépêchez vous de réserver certaines
séances affichent déjà complet
il